bon alors d'abord quelle personne
c'est une jeune fille de 18 ans 18 ans
ne te fais pas elle a entre 18 et 25 ans
si tu veux pourquoi doit-elle être belle
indispensablement avant toute chose il
ya un couple spa qui se dessine c'est
clitandre et armand bien donc elle doit
être jeune elle doit être belle
quel est son tempérament m quel est son
personnage elle est franche n'était
qu'une frange nette et claire bon et il
se trouve que qu'elle se trouve dans une
situation particulière quelle est cette
situation d'armande savoir quels sont
les projets de sa soeur non je te
demande pas exactement l'anecdote c'est
à dire l'histoire des femmes savantes
je te demande ce que tu vas pensée et
quel est ton but exact ont bu c'est
c'est la situation même d'obtenir
quelque chose de quelqu'un obtenir de ta
soeur premièrement qu'elle ne se marie
pas pour des raisons que nous allons
expliquer ensuite et deuxièmement que
toi tu puisses être heureuse at retour
pour des raisons aussi supplémentaire
donc avant toute chose obtenir quelque
chose de quelqu'un voilà la situation
[Musique]